vsauce kevin here and i am about to
stretch my winky until it
snaps actually i've got three of these
anti-stress emoji people called
winkies only one will survive
and you will witness an incredibly
simple problem that almost
everyone gets wrong and at the end get
to the bottom
of one of the most famous probability
problems
ever it's time to meet the winkies
orange purple and blue they've been
sentenced to death but just one will be
pardoned
the other two are walking the green mile
but
they don't know which two it will be
all they know is that i warden kevin
get to decide right now each winky's
chance of survival is
one out of three so one over three plus
one over three
plus one over three equals one with
every winky having an equal shot at
living
there's no paradox here yet
the fairest least biased way to choose
which winky lives
is to put three slips of paper into a
hat and randomly draw a color
and mix around your slips and here we go
but what if they know that
i drew a color yet i don't tell them
which one it is these winkies would be
left to wonder
who will live who will die and what
their own
personal odds of survival really are
kevin kevin kevin you can
tell me i can keep a secret tell me
who will live my winky is talking to me
and i think i recognize that voice a
keeper of internet history how'd you end
up on death row
anyway i can't tell you who survives
it's
it's just not fair and i definitely
can't tell you whether
you live or die i understand
you bear a heavy burden just tell me
one of the winkies that will be executed
if purple lives tell me blue if blue
lives
tell me purple and if i'm going to live
just choose which of the other two you'd
like to name do this for me kevin
please i don't i don't know orange winky
it really doesn't seem fair please given
pretty please you are so handsome and
those glasses look so good on you
okay what's the harm i can't possibly
give orange winky any useful information
here
okay blue will be executed
right now
i didn't mean to put his body back that
way upside down but you know what
warden kevin is uh is a cruel warden
kevin you fool now i know my odds are
50 50. i will live or
purple will live there is no alternative
you stupid stupid man oh he's so dumb
and also fat oh no he's right i got
tricked by a winky now there are only
two choices one will live and one will
not
so his odds improved from one out of
three to
fifty fifty right wrong orange winky
you still only have a one out of three
chance to live
and purple winky is actually twice as
likely to win
the pardon this may remind you of the
monty hall
problem and we'll get to why that's
important later but for now
let's break down the only possible
scenarios that orange winky
faced remember that i can't tell orange
winky
whether he lives or dies when i named
blue we can compare the
two possible outcomes after naming
blue scenario one where i name blue and
purple lives
has a one out of three probability of
occurring
scenario three where i name blue and
orange lives has a one out of
six chance of happening since one over
three is twice as large as one over
six and since they're the only two
possible
outcomes after naming blue meaning their
probabilities have to add up to
one purple actually has a two out of
three chance of survival and orange only
has a one out of three chance of
avoiding
execution the probabilities of two
events that
appear to be equally likely just
aren't and we can't handle that
all right it's time to reveal which wiki
will live and which winky
will die this slip of paper determines
our survivor and
purple lives sorry orange kevin time for
you to
no we have a message become history my
body is stretching
do not scratch me kevin no
was it because i called you fat
i am dead welcome to the three
prisoners problem which is actually the
bertrand's box paradox and
kind of the monty hall problem but
mostly the bertrand's box
paradox which came out the same year the
eiffel tower opened
van gogh painted the story night and
nintendo kopai first started producing
playing cards they eventually made video
games
in 1889 70 years before recreational
math columnist martin gardner
started playing mind games with
prisoners on their execution date
french mathematician joseph bertrand
published
calculate probability in which he posed
a paradox that became
the basis the genesis
for monty hall and will require
me to stick my winkies in pudding
let me explain after making me a plate
of
tendees in my favorite dipping sauce my
mom
secretly hid winkies in these three
large
candy dishes full of pudding one of them
contains two
winkies of the same color another one
contains two winkies of
a different color and then one contains
one winky
each of those two colors i'm pretty sure
that mom said one winky color
is yellow but i'm not sure what the
other one is
this is so much grosser than i thought
it was going to be
let's reveal this winky's color
oh thank you for licking me clean kevin
your tongue is so smooth
how are you alive you can't kill me
kevin
we're friends now okay well clearly we
have an orange winky
somehow back from the dead and we know
that the second winky color
is yellow but what are the chances that
the
other winky in this pudding is also
orange we know that the three dishes are
orange orange orange yellow and yellow
yellow each combination is equally
likely to be
chosen at the start we also know that
this can't be the yellow yellow dish
because
i just pulled out the creepiest orange
winky
on the planet that means it's coming
from orange orange
or from orange and yellow and both had
the same chance of
being selected once we pull the orange
winky
we know that the odds the other winky in
this dish is
orange is 50 50 because
i've clearly chosen either the orange
orange pudding or the
orange yellow pudding right wrong
again for the same mathematical reason
as
our prisoner problem this is the
mathematical foundation of all these
scenarios our inability to recognize
that what
appears to be 50 50 really
isn't hold on before i explain further
let's just find out real quick
where the winkies are because i actually
don't know
well this was orange orange ah so it was
orange orange
jar number two i can't even tell
yeah okay that's yellow now is this one
orange
or is this the yellow yellow jar time to
find out looks orange looks orange let's
see
yep there's the other orange so that was
our yellow orange which means
that this has to be the yellow yellow
yellow
yellow i already have to clean up this
pudding or else we can't continue the
video
so i'll be right back
[Music]
all right now that the vsauce mukbang
portion of our video is complete let's
get to the root
of this problem bertrand conceived his
original paradox
with gold and silver coins in boxes
he had the same basic setup we used gold
gold
gold silver and silver silver with the
player reaching into a random box
drawing a gold coin and wondering about
the odds of that box containing
another gold coin once we pull a gold
coin
or an orange winky or one of the
prisoners to be executed it feels like
our odds of
whatever comes next are an equal 50
50. we're just choosing between two
leftover options that appear to be
equally likely
we know the other coin is either gold
or silver but look if you pull a
gold coin you either pull gold coin one
gold coin two or three and at this point
you conceptually know that you're not
dealing with the box with the
two silver coins you don't know exactly
what it is but you do know
what it's not if you choose gold one the
other coin
is gold two if you choose gold two the
other coin is
gold 1. if you choose gold 3 you'll get
silver one so 2 out of 3 times you draw
gold it'll be paired with another gold
and only one time out of 3 will you get
stuck
with silver but it's almost impossible
to shake the notion
of two equivalent options even when
the math shows us that it's wrong it's
the same reason why
the monty hall problem is a problem
the prisoner problem and monty hall add
a story to the math
and an additional third party it seems
like that would make it
more complex but it actually helps you
understand the probability
more easily adding a second player's
perspective lets us see that
the warden will never reveal who lives
and monty hall will never reveal the
door
with the money despite that additional
information
we still get it wrong why is it so
hard when the solution is right in front
of our face
probably because it is right in front of
our face and it's why
very very smart people often get it more
wrong
than right i mentioned this in my what
is a paradox video but when marilyn
vos savant wrote in parade magazine that
switching doors in the monty hall
problem resulted in a two over three
chance of success
instead of being an obvious 50 50 trade
parade received over 10 000 letters
telling her
she was wrong about 1 000 of them were
signed by phds and
she claims many were sent on official
letterheads from college math
and science departments and i still get
comments on my video from people
all over the world telling me that i'm
wrong massimo piatelli paul marini
author of
inevitable illusions said that no other
statistical puzzle comes
close to fooling all the people all the
time
and research in 1995 by granzberg and
brown
found that only 13 of people
correctly switched monty hall's
doors in a 2003 paper in the journal of
experimental psychology stephan krauss
and xt
wang described these particular problems
from
bertrand's box to monty hall as
cognitive
illusion stating that they demonstrate
people's resistant deficiency in dealing
with
uncertainty they found that only three
percent in the control group
solved the problem with mathematically
correct
reasoning and that a significant problem
was
perspective when participants were able
to think of the problem from the
perspective of
monty hall instead of the game show
contestant
or thinking as me warden kevin
instead of as the prisoner orange winky
their chances of choosing the right
pathway improved vaulting them
from simple non-bayesian thinking into
more complex bayesian analysis
in the 1990s it appeared that there was
no way
to break the mathematical illusion of
bertrand's box the
three prisoners or the monty hall
problem
explaining the math just didn't seem to
work
it turns out the math isn't the problem
we are uncertainty is hard
for us changing perspectives is harder
you're watching this video because
you're a smart
curious person and by altering your
perspective
you don't just dismiss a mathematical
illusion that has perplexed us for over
a century because you've identified its
flaw
you don't just solve it you embrace
it you absorb it you understand it and
you
ultimately use it to your advantage
you know it and i know that i have
so much pudding to eat and as always
no thanks for watching
pudding i mean surprise
[Music]
you